Speaker 1: I want to point to some interesting
threads that appeared on The David Pakman Show
sub Reddit. You can join the discussion along with
more than thirty two thousand. Can you imagine?
Thirty two thousand of our viewers and listeners
currently subscribed to the sub Reddit.
Find it at David Pakman dot com slash red dot. One
post says, Right now I feel like covid will never
end in the United States. So looking more and
more like covid will never end due to active AXA's
and I feel pretty hopeless about it. It
essentially means it's just going to be
one locked down after another that I'm never going
to get to meet new people again. And vaccinating
the world won't happen either. Right now I feel
like ending it is all. It ending it all is the
only solution because of climate change and
covid never ending extremely depressing post,
extremely depressing because we are going to get
past it at a certain point, everyone will either
be vaccinated or will have gotten sick. Of course,
the effect of the variance is a question mark,
but it is only a matter of time. The question
is how much time is that going to be?
But we are going to talk momentarily about now
even Republicans all of a sudden saying, hey, it's
it's time to get vaccinated. So don't lose hope.
Don't lose hope. I do. I am sure we are going to
get past that. It's just a question of how many
people are going to die in the meantime and what
what is going to come next. Another poster posted
a clip from Sam Sanders Show Majority report where
George W. Bush says that it breaks his heart to
see troops removed from Afghanistan. I don't have
too much more to say about this. I've already said
before, yeah, we broke it. And when you break it,
you have some responsibility to stay until it's
fixed. But it's very clear we're not going to fix
it. It's very clear that just staying longer in
Afghanistan because we're the cause of the problem
is not likely to actually bring a better situation
to the Afghani people. And at a certain point, we
have to say, listen, it's been Bush, Obama, Trump,
Biden, it's time to get out. It's time to get out.
And this is just a reminder that even when George
W. Bush says something mildly reasonable when
it comes to his perspective on Donald Trump, we
shouldn't see George W. Bush as much more than the
neocon warmonger that we knew him to be during
his two terms in office. And then this is funny,
a little more lighthearted. A post appeared saying
congratulations for 16 years. I know I'm a few
days late, but I want to congratulate David on 16
years on the air. Last thing, four times longer
than the Confederacy. No, you're not a few days
late. You're a month earlier. It's it's not July
16th. It is at the end of the day on August 16th
that it will be our 16th anniversary. So I love
the sentiment. I appreciate it. But you're not
late at all. You're actually very early. And
for that we can all be very, very glad. Joined
the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom. Read it